[Music]
welcome to science podcast for January
11 2009 teen I'm Sara Krusty this week's
show Megan Cantwell talks with Justin
Reich about massive open online courses
also known as MOOCs after coming online
more than a decade ago some of them are
starting to pivot to a money-making
model justin suggests there might be
some good reasons for that and I talked
with Christina Warner about a skeleton
with mysterious microscopic blue
crystals stuck in a Tartar of her teeth
for more than a thousand years Christina
and archeo geneticists ended up
collaborating with physicists and
historians to figure out what the
substance was where it came from and how
it came to be attached to the skeletons
teeth MOOCs or massive open online
courses gained lots of attention in 2012
as a way to make education accessible
globally through access to free video
lectures and assignments from some of
the world's best professors many
enrolled in these courses but
unfortunately the attrition rate was
also quite high I'm Megan Cantwell and
I'm here with Justin Reich to talk about
the state of MOOCs in 2019 and why some
are now offering online master's degrees
for professionals hey Justin hi how are
you thanks for having me
yeah it's great to have you on could you
just give a background on how MOOCs were
started sure in 2006 2007 2008 there
were a group of mostly Canadian
educators who were doing really
interesting innovative work with
launching online classes on the open web
classes usually had a course number at a
university but then they put all the
materials online so everyone who wanted
to could join in and they had a couple
thousand folks who would arrive to those
classes and then in 2011 there are a few
different folks in California who were
enthusiastic about the idea including
Peter Norvig and Sebastian Thrun and
they had over a hundred thousand people
signed up to their introduction day AI
class so it was sort of an idea that
caught fire
what was the goal of providing this
service you know there are a number of
the key principles at the beginning of
this who said our goal is to really
widely disseminate these learning
opportunities they sort of hope that it
would be
kind of a blue ocean market disinvest
what it's called in Silicon Valley terms
that there would be a a whole vast array
of people who weren't consuming this
service that would be potential
consumers that they could spread widely
especially in places that didn't have
access to lots of higher education what
problems did they see emerge from these
programs as they spread to these areas
people have studied distance education
for a long time and self-regulated
learning is really hard it's really hard
to to say I'm gonna make some extra
space in my life to take this course and
persist all the way through it it's
proven much easier to have people who
already have access to higher education
get access to more higher education
through this kind of free unstructured
online learning than it is to sort of
create new on-ramps into higher
education although there are incredible
stories of people from every single walk
of life every single background you've
encountered MOOCs and a really great
powerful learning experiences from them
there's a pretty high rate of people who
end up not continuing their MOOC or soon
after they started they stopped it has
this problem persisted or worsened over
time or has it pretty much just been a
problem throughout we have good access
to Harvard and MIT data and so we can
make claims about what we see in that
typically about half the people who
register for a course never show up or
click into it at all that's not a big
deal it's totally fine for people to
indicate interest in something and then
not decide to pursue that interest and
that hasn't really changed very much
what has somewhat gone down at least in
Harvard and MIT data is the proportion
of people who returned after a second
year and most of the folks who come and
join a Harvard X or MIT X course don't
come back the following year for a
subsequent course and that proportion of
folks has gotten smaller with each
subsequent year both as a total number
of people who have enrolled has gone up
for Fears and then gone down more in
recent years but that that's been sort
of a stable trend one of the particular
challenges I think the courses is like
when someone signs up for Twitter or
signs up for Instagram there's no
logical ending point your feet just sort
of keep scrolling over and over again
but courses in as that ends people go
off and they do other things it's just
hard to build a lot of growth when you
have this sort of natural breaking point
once they realize that these problems
are
persisting did they do anything to
address them or was there any way for
them to address it some colleagues and I
have published some studies where we've
tried different sorts of interventions
based on social psychology or behavioral
economics and we've had some initial
evidence that those things might work
although as we've replicated them over
time we haven't seen all of the gains
that we might hope building a course
that you can really learn something from
that really advances the science of
learning is much more resource intensive
than just getting a course out there
that teaches some people stuff
universities are typically trying to
take the budgets they have to make new
courses and to spread them widely across
lots of different groups so that the
money spread fairly and so that lots of
courses can get made and it's hard to
get your course out there on a budget on
a deadline and have a whole research
agenda that's going along in parallel
with it
yeah these programs definitely need
money to sustain and previously they
started out by selling certificates of
completion as a revenue stream but now
they're shifting to a different revenue
model could you talk a little bit about
that there's some emerging consensus
conversion around online masters degree
programs or other kinds of programs that
are targeted at working professionals
some of this is not brand new so Udacity
very early on had an interesting
partnership with Georgia Tech where they
created the online master's degree in
computer science Coursera
announced that they were gonna make more
partnerships with schools to offer fully
online kind of MOOC based master's
degrees the pivot to supporting
universities and creating master's
degrees puts these providers competing
with a lot of well-established
organizations that help universities
that create online master's degrees and
are these MOOCs run differently in
comparison to these more
well-established programs one trend
might be that a lot of the established
organizations that have helped
universities create online courses have
mostly focused on courses with staffing
models that most people would recognize
from older online education but there's
20 25 40 students in the class if
there's one instructor but there's some
sense of connection you know if there's
not at all the scale that you see like
in the Georgia Tech online
computer science masters where they're
really trying to do a combination of
automating quite a bit of the
instruction and then you know some some
interesting labor models where Udacity
has a network of people around the world
that grade people's assignments there's
not one ta sitting at Georgia Tech or
there's not thirty ta sitting around a
table at Georgia Tech or grading all
these things they're taking advantage of
crowdsourcing and sort of other models
to try to find new economies of scale in
teaching so this pivot to professional
degree programs with MOOCs has there
been any comparison yet between the
retention rate with these programs
versus more well-established programs no
and it's gonna take a while because the
programs are designed to complement
working professionals we have under
review right now another paper that
we're doing which is a review of MIT
first micro masters program the supply
chain management program you know and
the amount of work that people put into
these classes sort of in the corners and
nooks and crannies of their lives you
know just people describing to us like I
go sit at my desk at lunch and I fire up
some videos like I stay after work late
into the night doing these things so
it's pretty hard to make it a kind of
full-time commitment the way that these
are set up you know as a result it's a
little bit tricky to figure out when
people have a traded from the program
when they've really left it's not
necessarily a bad thing if someone's
poking along at one course a year and it
takes them a lot longer to finish but
they are able to do that and they meet
their goals one thing that might be a
good thing is that if the costs of these
programs are reduced you know you're
paying them per course or credit and the
risk is also distribute you're not sort
of paying up front for a big program and
things like that so overall would you
say that the programs through MOOCs are
more affordable than these other online
degree programs and the target audience
for the MOOC programs are different than
the traditional online programs there's
one study that's out on this and again
it said with this first sort of Georgia
Tech class they did a neat study where
for idiosyncratic reasons no one knew
that they made in the admissions process
at grade cut score so if you were below
this cut score you didn't have a chance
of getting admitted if you're above the
cut score you could be considered
and of course people just above and
below that truck score are not actually
different from one another it's you know
there's a sort of a bit of randomization
so you can look at people on either side
of that cut score and see sort of what
happens to them and people above the cut
score would go in many of them went into
the Georgia Tech program and the people
who didn't get into the program they
didn't pursue other options so the
argument that Josh and his colleagues
make is that this is sort of genuinely
creating new kinds of pathways for
people how big the demand is kind of
remains to be seen but it's an
interesting model so what do you think
is the future of MOOCs given this pivot
to professional degrees my colleague
Mimi Ito says that people often hope
that new technologies will disrupt
existing systems and oftentimes new
technologies get domesticated by
existing systems and so one future you
can imagine here is what you might call
a sort of productive domestication that
in various nooks and crannies mostly
focused on sort of professional
education master's degree programs there
are some ways that already educated
people can get some cheaper more
efficient more in a sort of lined with
their work life schedule degrees through
these programs if we saw that as the
case you know one good lesson that might
emerge from that is that as there are
sort of inevitably new technologies that
catch the attention of Education
administrators and education
policymakers a good stance to take is
something along the lines of oh there's
probably like neat ways that this new
technology can help us do what we're
doing better in particular kinds of ways
but it's unlikely that any particular
new technology is going to lead to a
sort of dramatic reorganization of
higher education particularly around the
most pressing challenges of how do we
support first-generation students how do
we create more access opportunities in
places that are physically distant from
centers of higher education those
challenges I think technology can play a
role in engaging but in many ways those
challenges will remain sort of political
challenges and policy challenges you
know where we make investments more so
than new technologies that precise a
grand reordering of things all right
thanks so much Justin you bet thanks so
much for having me
Justin rake is an assistant professor in
the comparative Media Studies department
at the Massachusetts Institute of
Technology you can find a link to his
piece at science mag
slash podcast stay tuned for
Aric recipes interview with kristina
warner about mysterious crystals in the
teeth of a thousand-year-old skeleton
[Music]
when you go to the dentist there's this
pleasant process where they scrape your
teeth and they take is called dental
calculus or tartar off your teeth no but
luckily that is a relatively new thing
and back in a day and like medieval
times people were not having their teeth
scraped every three to six months and I
say lucky because there is precious
information hidden in that dental
calculus and we've been able to learn
things about the oral microbiome of the
people who lived in the past and also
about different diseases that they might
have had and now it's also telling us
things about their occupation what they
did everyday or what kinds of chemicals
they encountered in their lives I have a
Christina at Warner here she's gonna
talk about some dental calculus that was
contaminated with a blue mineral so
Christina what did you find these blue
particles associated with the dental
calculus on these remains was any when
we first saw them I mean it was probably
the last thing I would have expected to
find we were trying to look at diet in
house yeah we expected to see bacteria
because after all calculus is made of
plaque dental plaque and which is made
up of bacteria and we expected to find
little bits of soot because when you're
alive and you have plaque on your teeth
and you're eating or you're smoking or
you're breathing in pollen all these
little things get stuck in your plaque
over time the plaque calcifies it
mineral eise's in your mouth from the
minerals in your saliva in fact it's the
only part of your body that fossilizes
while you're still alive
and this actually happens over and over
again these layers actually build up
almost like tree rings or layers of an
onion so after you've calcified one
layer you'll form another layer of Delta
plaque and keep doing it
this woman that we looked at we actually
cross sectioned it and there were so
many layers it really looked like this
calculus hadn't been removed in 20 or 25
years it had so many layers built on top
of each other but for an archaeologist
this is a gold mine it's like a time
capsule that tells the story of this
woman's life what was the first thought
from the group if you know they saw
these little blue flecks in her teeth
under the microscope we had no idea what
it was I thought could it be some sort
of
is there something in soil that's blue
yeah no no there's not we looked into it
extensively actually blue minerals are
very rare they tend to be things you
have to mined from deep in the earth
they don't occur and surface sediments
so we thought well maybe maybe it's a
it's a mineral of some kind and maybe
it's a paint because a certainly it was
so blue it was royal blue it was the
brightest brightest blue it looked like
Robins eggs
tiny little Robin I thought at first it
was probably as right as you're right is
a pretty common mineral it's a pretty
inexpensive mineral and it's really
widespread across Europe and it was used
by artists in the Middle Ages so I was
pretty sure it was as you're right it
ended up being fairly complicated to
identify for a number of reasons one is
as we were looking at it the blue began
to fade and disappear oh yeah this
happened over and over again it took a
while for us to figure out what was
happening and we finally figured it out
when you want to look at calculus under
a microscope you can't just put it under
a microscope it's too compacted and you
can't see anything you have to break it
up and the usual way of doing this is to
apply a little bit of weak acid and it
just dissolves the mineral enough to
allow the particles to come out it turns
out that many mineral pigments are
actually unstable in the presence of
acid and they lose their color mm-hmm
and that's what we were seeing so that
gave you a clue that maybe it wasn't as
you're right well as rate also breaks
down we actually tested many different
reference pigments and and determined
which were stable in which were not so
like cobalt blues is stable but as write
is not and lapis lazuli was not mm-hmm
there aren't that many blues that were
available to the medieval painter they
had a committed access of the blues that
they had available to most are blue
because of a particular element so
cobalt blue is blue because of cobalt
Azure ides blue because of copper
vivianne dye is blue because of iron
lapis lazuli is actually not one mineral
it's a bunch of minerals together the
blue component is called lazurite
there's also white minerals and they're
called phlogopite and also pyrite the
golden flecks that people often
recognize one thing your paper reminded
me of is that in a television show and
they say what is this mineral residue
and they just hand it to the lab and
they'll have hands and packet and answer
it is never that easy you had to go
through a lot of steps to identify what
exactly what
is going on here on these teeth so what
were some of the tests that you had to
subject to this mineral - well the
trouble with lacerate though the blue
mineral is that there's nothing unusual
about it in terms of its elements it's
made up of the same elements that are
found in soil they're just configured
very differently into in their mineral
structure and so we use a technique
called Raman spectroscopy which actually
allows us to look more at the mineral
structure itself and that we were able
to get a very good match for lies right
after we've identified the blue crystals
as being a match using two different
methods for lazurite we thought well
let's test some of these white particles
that ordinarily would completely ignore
and they turned out to be so occupied I
know largely right and flog bite only
co-occur together in lapis lazuli so
that gave you that confidence that you
knew exactly what you were looking at
but it's really surprising that that's
what you were looking at it was
extremely surprising lapis lazuli was
one of the most expensive and rarest
artist materials of the Middle Ages we
did not expect to find it I think it's
hard for us to understand how expensive
it was and how difficult it would have
been to get there lapis lazuli only had
one source during the Middle Ages and
that was Afghanistan so this pigment had
to have traveled from its source in
Afghanistan overland along the paths of
the Silk Road basically and through the
Islamic world whereas probably refined
into a pigment traded up into Venice and
then distributed into Europe it made an
extraordinary 6000 kilometer journey to
make it into the mouth of this very
ordinary well what about that what about
that last little bit of the journey
how would it end up in her mouth I mean
there's no way this could happen
completely accidentally she must have
been exposed in a very intimate way but
how could that possibly happen yeah we
spent a long time debating what the
possible scenarios could be I have my
favorite it's not the one that it is my
favorite is all the book kissing that
people were doing at the time what you
think yes so so this is really
incredible during the Middle Ages but
but actually later than this what
eliminated it yeah yeah during the 14th
century if there's this sort of fad for
what they call a motive
auscultation so this is like intense
kissing of books and the idea was to
become very affectionate with the images
eventually they started creating these
little auscultation targets at the
bottoms of the pages to try to encourage
priests for example to kiss the target
and not the face of Jesus because it was
wiping away his faith that one was
discarded because it was it wasn't that
the timing wasn't right and let's turn
to one of the what are the likely
scenarios in which this woman would have
introduced this into her mouth so we
came up with to do we thought were more
likely that either she was trying to
produce a pigment herself and thus may
have inhaled some of the dust if that
was so she would probably be producing
it either for herself or one of her
sisters or she was an artist herself
with the first scenario although it's
possible I don't think it's likely for
one reason and that is because if you
just take lapis lazuli stone and you
grind it yeah you'll get a really dull
gray pigment it's not nice it has too
much of the flog of Pi and other
minerals inside that dole the color so
what you have to do is you have to
refine it and the technique used to
refine lapis lazuli at this time wasn't
really known in Europe it was primarily
performed in in the Islamic world but
what I think is probably the most likely
is that she was an artist herself we do
know from some artists manuals around
the same time that one technique for
producing a really fine point for for
fine painting work involved compressing
the paint brush between the lips the
lapis lazuli was quite distributed
through her mouth so it wasn't dust in
one place it was also really dispersed
so it didn't seem to have been
incorporated as a paint for example if
she had kissed it and it gotten stuck
and also there are some really amazing
letters from right around the same time
period maybe a little bit later also in
Germany where there is a men's monastery
there's an AR Marius who is the keeper
of the books and he had commissioned the
production of several new books from a
neighboring women's community so when
you say when you say she was an artist
it's more about illuminating manuscripts
and it is about making painting
correct okay it was very likely for
illuminating manuscripts because there
was a lot of book production right at
this time it gives evidence that women
were producing books and they were in
producing important books yeah but
unfortunately these letters don't stay
which pigments were being used we can
tell by the amount of silk and the
amount of parchment that he was sending
for these books to be made that they
would have been quite nice books is
there anything else from the gravesite
or from the ruins of the monastery where
were this these remains were or is there
anything else there that would help with
that the women's community from the
letter was a different one okay I was
not this community the remains are from
a site called dal hime dal home is
located in western Germany and today
it's actually the site of a museum about
monasteries and the the cemetery that we
focus on was one of the very was
associate with one of the earliest
religious communities that was founded
in this area and it was a women's
community what's interesting about Saul
Haim is almost nothing survives at all
today if you can go and visit and I
recommend doing so it's really fun but
all that's left of the women's community
is the stone foundations none of the
walls are there there's no art that
survives there's not a single book that
survives this poor woman's community
which at it's at its height supported
actually a very small group of women
only about a dozen women live there at
any given time it underwent multiple
fires it burned to the ground multiple
times it was sacked in at least two
battle it was hit by plague and
eventually it was abandoned during
another war and a nun was murdered and
the whole community fell apart this was
centuries later and then later a group
of monks moved in and they built a
monastery and that's the monastery that
actually really survives there today and
that today is really the museum people
go to visit but you can still find this
kind of traces of this little woman's
what they call a frauen closer this
little women's monastery a little
women's community still there the church
foundations and the foundations of the
place where they lived but it's very
small and kind of tucked away and
forgotten it's like it had just been a
rape Wow absolutely erased and so to me
that was something that was so
interesting is
in this totally unexpected context from
this very ordinary seeming woman from
this cemetery we've been able to
identify someone who was likely in life
quite an extraordinary person she must
have been a very talented artist when I
say artists here because lapis largely
was not used by scribes it was not used
typically to write words it was used to
illuminate pictures Wow
that is amazing so other other remains
from this site that that might be able
to shed more light on this
we only in this initial study looked at
four individuals and that was because we
had a completely different purpose to
the study originally I think what this
has shown me is that this could be a
really important way of going back and
revisiting many monasteries and
identifying artists and craftspeople hmm
one of the big lessons we learned here
is it's also very important how you
analyze the calculus in most cases what
people would normally do is start the
decalcification with the acid walk away
wait till it was finished come back all
of it would have been gone so it made me
wonder how many artists have already
been looked at but because of the way
the calculus was treated we never saw it
yeah so one of the things we want to go
back apply these newer techniques and to
see if we could kind of approach this in
a different way I start to identify the
artists themselves in the archaeological
record how common was it for women
during this time to be scribes or to be
artists involved in book making it's a
fantastic question and this is something
that Alison beech who's the historian of
the project has researched extensively
and she's turned up quite a bit of
evidence of women who were prolific
producers of books but a lot of
detective work has had to go into this
because one of the challenges we face is
women often did not sign their works in
some cases a list survives on a nun the
later nun for example would write down
that sister so and so wrote these books
but if you'd look at the books
themselves nothing indicates that what
she was also able to do is take one book
that was signed and matched the
handwriting to several other anonymous
books and so we could see okay this
was all written by one person and here
it signs so we can apply that name to
all of them but it's really painstaking
work to try to reconstruct this and so I
think it's really helpful to have this
second line of evidence I mean many
people might think that archaeologists
and historians work together because we
work on kind of similar things but
actually it doesn't happen that often we
kind of exist in different worlds one
group lives in libraries and one group
digs in the dirt and those are very so
you guys are not all Indiana Jones no
we're quite different you know here was
a really great problem that we all got
to sit together and really talk about
and then we needed more so we teamed up
with physicists so it was a fun project
where we really had archaeologists
historians and physicists all sitting
together talking trying to puzzle out
this question and that was tremendous
fun that is really cool really seems
like this is a totally different way of
doing archaeology who would have thought
that if you wanted to understand artists
in the Middle Ages you would look at
their dental plaque yeah sometimes I
think we get tripped up with thinking
that artifacts are only stone tools and
pottery but there is this entire
archaeology of the invisible that is out
there that we are only now starting to
appreciate things decompose and break
down at a large scale but many of the
microscopic particles and the
biomolecules actually preserved for a
really really long time yeah I feel like
we're right now kind of in this
Renaissance of archaeology I feel like
with a lot of the new scientific
technologies that are available we're
kind of a new kind of archaeology as
being born and I'm really excited about
it
very cool okay thank you again christine
has been really fun thanks so much
Christina Warner is a professor in the
Department of Archaeology nedick's at
the Max Planck Institute for the science
of human history you can find a link to
her research in science advances at
science mad or clash podcasts and that
concludes this edition of the science
podcast if you have any comments or
suggestions for the show write to us at
science podcast at AAAS o RG you can
subscribe to the show anywhere you get
your podcasts or you can listen on the
Science website
science mag cast to place an ad on the
science podcast contact mid-roll calm
this show is produced by Sarah crusty
and Meghan Cantwell and edited by Potter
G Jeffrey cook composed the music on
behalf of science magazine and its
publisher triple-a us thanks for joining
us